the Navy has removed the commander of a
coronavirus stricken aircraft carrier
over a letter he wrote obtained by the
media pleading for help after more than
100 sailors had tested positive to cope
at 19 the acting Navy secretary says
captain Brett Crozier's actions
undermined the chain of command and
caused alarm to me that demonstrated
extremely poor judgment in the middle of
a crisis because what it's done it's
created a firestorm it's created doubts
about the ship's ability to go to see if
it needs to it's created doubt among the
families about the health of their
sailors and that was a completely
unnecessary thing to do in the midst of
a crisis and of course politics mixed in
a bit top Democrats have gone after the
move as an overreaction some sailors
appeared to rally behind their commander
as he left the USS Theodore Roosevelt
watch
[Applause]
joining me now chairman of the joint
chiefs of staff general mark Milley sir
thank you for being on the program
taking the time today I want to know
whether you think this was an easy or a
tough decision for the acting Navy
secretary and why Harris thanks for the
opportunity I'm over here at FEMA doing
some interagency coordination but
specific to the Teddy Roosevelt in the
relief of the ship's captain secretary
motely
clearly there's a difficult decisions
none of them are ever easy and it's his
estimation he lost trust and confidence
in the ship's captain so he secretary
moly is the responsible and accountable
official to the American people and he
had reason to believe that that the that
the captain operated outside the chain
of command and he relieved him it's not
the type of decision that you would make
well I'm not in the position right now
with there's an ongoing investigation I
don't have all the facts but I trust
secretary motely in his judgment and I'm
going to support him obviously because
he is the responsible and accountable
official to the American people and the
ship's captain and in secretary mode Lee
explained it
he thought he operated it with poor
judgment in a time of crisis and they
operate outside the chain of command
sorry relieved him and we're going to
move on and make sure that the sailors
of that ship are taken care of and that
the readiness of the ship is back up to
speed and we're going to continue to
focus on responding to the needs of the
American people for Co vid 19 and I
should mention that the Acting Secretary
of the Navy was on with me yesterday and
he said that they had already some
things in motion because it takes a lot
more than just 24 hours after a letter
would drop to move 3,000 people real
quickly just to hit this one more time
and then I want to move on you mentioned
FEMA and I know you have those hospital
ships our correspondent Jen Griffin
through sources learned that the DoD and
White House officials some of them had
warned against doing this making this
kind of quick decision about captain
Crozier just a quick thought about that
I'm not aware of any White House or DoD
officials who warned against making
quick decisions that maybe I don't know
I do know that the Secretary of the Navy
is responsible to the American people
for the good order and discipline of the
Navy
and when he loses trust and confidence
in a ship's captain then that's it its
target down and we're moving on to the
next the next task when anytime a
Secretary of the Navy secretary of
defense presen United States or sperry
commissioned officer loses trust and
confidence in a subordinate and the
subordinate goes all right I see the
jackets of FEMA standing behind you and
you mentioned where you are tell me
about the comfort that hospital ships
the comfort and the mercy comfort
obviously here on the East Coast the
mercy on on in Los Angeles what they're
doing well right now as you know both
the comfort and emergency were deployed
at the end of last month with the Mercy
going to Los Angeles Comfort going to
New York City they went up there they've
arrived they are fully operational
they've got some small amount of
patients right now the intent originally
was for them to take the overflow of
trauma patients out of the local
hospitals so that the local hospitals
could focus on the kovat patients we're
reassessing that now and the Secretary
of Defense is making a risk assessment
to determine whether or not we should
take on all the kovat patients to
relieve some of the local hospitals
right now both hospitals ships are there
thousand beds each as you all know
multiple capabilities on those ships in
addition to the hospital ship so you've
got four field hospitals deployed in New
York City Seattle down in down in Dallas
and New Orleans as well
we've got other capabilities the Navy's
got to EMFs expeditionary medical
facilities we stood up 15 additional
field hospitals on the Army last night
we've got about 450 doctors and well
over a thousand nurses committed
nationwide out of the US military in
support of various civilian communities
we're providing supplies we've already
provided five million Mass we've got
five million more masks in route we've
set aside 2,000 ventilators we've got 18
or 19,000 National Guardsmen
contributing to the fight and we're
going to continue to pile on until we
have expended all our resources to
protect the American people right so the
US military is here and we are here to
help and we are grateful as a nation a
couple of things and I'm sure you're
well aware of the fact that there's been
some criticism
after learning that the Pentagon had so
many masks but didn't know where to send
it so first I'm cured
send them rather I'm curious to know is
you tick down all of those things that
you're bringing to the table how you
know where the need is coming and and
how do you quell that criticism that
headwind of stuff sitting where do we
send it sure yeah what are they I mean
the way the system works is the need is
first identified at the local community
municipality or the state level they
bring it in to the federal level through
FEMA initially it was HHS and then that
shifted over to FEMA so FEMA is the
focal point in fact where I'm at right
now is the command post for FEMA and
it's the focal point for all local
requests and demands and requirements
they come in here and then those
requests are determined which
governmental agency can best satisfy the
need in many cases it's Department of
Defense so they send the requests over
to the department defense we look
through the inventory and we deploy the
assets that are necessary to help out so
that's how the requests work in addition
to that there's an informal method where
are given mayor or governor who might
talk to the secretary defense or myself
or or perhaps someone in the White House
and we'll get that through an informal
methodology but the formal requests come
through FEMA over to the Department of
Defense and down into the down into the
community that seems general that seems
to be a streamline that you guys have
have answered back with because as you
mentioned it didn't always work that way
just real quickly some criticism here on
on the East Coast because a lot of the
patients now that are presenting at
hospitals and I know you say you can
skip that now and go straight to the
ships they have Cove in nineteen I mean
we saw our largest number of deaths in
New York yesterday how well-equipped are
these hospital ships in these field
hospitals to handle when a Cove in
nineteen maybe asymptomatic maybe
somebody who didn't know as sick as they
were till they got to the ship how are
you guys ready for that well these are
hospital ships and there's full fledged
doctors and nurses on them now the
thousand bed hospital ship comfort for
example about four or five hundred of
those beds are actually litters that are
stacked on top of each other so those
are really holding facility so you got
about 500 or so med surg type and you
got 11 ICU beds and so on and you've got
4050 that can go into isolation can you
contained absolutely I think that our
medical facilities both on the ships in
the MTFs that are at the different forts
and camps in the field hospitals for
example that's getting set up in Javits
Center they can and will if required
handle the Cova 19 patients for sure a
pleasure and an honor to have the Joint
Chiefs of Staff chairman on outnumbered
overtime today sir thank you very much
thanks Harris appreciate the opportunity